[Música]
demos una mirada a los mercados en la
jornada de hoy hablamos de economía me
acompañan el estudio Jorge Hurtado Jorge
muy buenas noches Tenemos que hablar de
Turquía y el impacto que tiene este
terremoto en la economía de ese país que
ya venía con problemas Bueno en palabras
del presidente es la peor catástrofe en
todo un siglo la liga turca cayó
brevemente hasta un mínimo histórico y
su principal mercado bursátil cayó un
1,35% también el rendimiento de la deuda
pública local a diez años alcanzó su
nivel más alto en casi dos meses con un
10,2%, al menos cuatro aeropuertos
turcos resultaron dañados según las
autoridades y más de 2,800 edificios
cayeron en Turquía entre Los afectados
también están los 3,7 millones de
refugiados sirios registrados en Turquía
Turquía detuvo el flujo de petróleo
hacia la terminal de exportación de
seiyang en la costa mediterránea como
una medida de precaución aunque no se
detectaron fugas en estos sólidos ductos
que alimentan esa instalación él seguían
es un centro vital para las ventas de
petróleo el puerto exportó más de un
millón de barriles diarios En enero eso
representa aproximadamente el 1% del
suministro mundial de petróleo ese
cierre contribuyó a la subida de los
precios a nivel internacional pasemos
ahora a hablar de Indonesia de ese país
el producto interno bruto sube a 5,31%
en 2022 niveles prepandemia Bueno
hablamos de la mayor Economía del
sudeste asiático y la decimoséptima
mundial que mostró una recuperación
total en el 2022 los datos superan
ligeramente las previsiones del gobierno
para 2022 que se encontraban entre el
5,2 y el cinco coma tres por ciento en
2021 es economía repuntó un 3,69% tras
registrar en 2020 su primera gran
contracción del
2,07% en más de dos décadas esto por
supuesto por la pandemia del Coby 19
para 2023 el banco de Indonesia prevé
una subida de entre el 4,5 25,3%
Mientras que el fondo monetario
internacional proyecta un crecimiento
para ese país del 4,8% Tenemos que
hablar Jorge de la entrada en vigencia
de la prohibición al diésel ruso que
dice Bueno esta prohibición y la de
otros derivados petrolíferos de Rusia es
parte del mecanismo de sanciones por la
invasión en Ucrania pero de los nuevos
derivados prohibidos el mayor desafío
actualmente es el veto al diesel que
emplean cerca de la mitad de los
vehículos de la Unión Europea y la mayor
parte del transporte pesado marítimo y
también la maquinaria el 40% de las
importaciones de la Unión Europea venían
de Rusia antes de la guerra pero
Bruselas Confía en que este periodo de
transición desde el inicio de las
sanciones que fue en junio del año
pasado hasta que se apliquen ahora mismo
en febrero de este año según ellos hayan
sido suficientemente largo para
garantizar rutas de suministro
alternativas Eso sí Moscú ha facturado a
la Unión Europea 140.000 millones de
euros en carbón gas y petróleo desde que
inició la Guerra en Ucrania hace ya hace
un año esto según el centro para la
investigación en energía y aire limpio
hablemos ahora de nuestra región de
América Latina porque el presidente de
Brasil criticó al Banco Central de ese
país por mantener los tipos de interés
altos el presidente brasileño afirmó que
no existe ninguna justificación para
mantener la tasa de interés de
referencia en el 13,75% anual y que
según él era una vergüenza el presidente
pidió ayuda a la clase empresarial que
en su opinión necesita aprender a
protestar por estos tipos de interés
alto para que presionen al Banco Central
con el objetivo de reducir la tasa de
interés El Banco Central decidió
mantener por cuarta vez consecutivas los
tipos oficiales en el 13,75% anual
manteniéndolos en sus niveles más alto
desde el año 2016 al considerar que la
inflación actualmente que está en 5,79%
anual continúa siendo una amenaza para
la economía brasileña La mayoría de
organismos económicos internacionales
aconsejan a los bancos centrales
mantener elevado los tipos de interés
para comba la inflación que afecta a la
mayoría de países del Mundo desde
Estados Unidos el expresidente Jair
bolsonaro expresó que el norte de el
país lo marca la economía y que no se
siente optimista con el futuro económico
brasileño por las medidas que está
tomando
Lula da Silva y pasemos ahora a la cifra
del día para el cierre
4.200 millones de dólares eso invertirán
47 empresas y organizaciones en el norte
de Centroamérica así lo anunció la
vicepresidenta estadounidense kamala
Harris esto como parte de su Apuesta por
reducir la migración Jorge muchas
gracias por esta actualización del mundo
de la economía continuación en directo
América ya viene el debate
[Música]